i feel like we have to start where we
left things off we're in the middle of
this
off the rails dinner that happens down
the shore
why why did that night take the turn
that it did
well let's be real i think the vibrator
started the situation
it's kind of big jack can i don't know
if it's going to fit up your ass but
maybe you should no stop
stop theresa i think it's fair to say
that we all were a little taken
back when that was presented and it was
told for for jackie to shove it up
harass i think that's
really what started it i could see it in
jackie's face that she was
the girl's hurting she really is like
she's not taking it the way
it's not just like getting brushed off
her shoulders she's not she's really
hurting like we can't keep doing this to
this woman because
she's she's breaking she's breaking
she's very upset and i was already
irritated by that vibe and i was mad
that i could feel the energy was already
not
in the right spot on the first night you
know
well yeah it just felt like stuff just
kept getting stacked on top of
i honestly did not even expect theresa
to turn to you during the
have i ever talked on you a moment
you call me a shredder let's be real i
mean there's no way i could ever like
lie for her there because they can flash
back to like 15
different episodes so i'm like i'd love
to back you up here but like i'm gonna
end up looking like the liar
you know so you know it's just like
let's just call a spade a spade
sometimes like i'm
past like oh my god that's why i wanted
if i could teach anything to like the
new girls it's like
oh like just say what you want to say
no matter what i even get frustrated at
margaret at this dinner because it's
like
no yell point your anger in the right
direction
like i don't want anyone don't be scared
speak your mind
and put your anger in the right
direction that really is a lesson you've
learned over the last i mean it's almost
been a decade that you've been on the
show
um you've been very open this season
about the frustrations of the last
decade of dealing with
theresa in this group um and then this
season you've spoken on that i feel like
jackie is arguing with theresa the way
i've done in the past
women could cheat men why are you
talking about cheating apologize to me
don't tell me to apologize to you it was
so important to me
to use logic and to explain to her why
she is wrong
but i've learned that she doesn't get my
point did she have any response to those
comments you made
no because i think she knows it's true
it's like
she's not the easiest person to like go
back and forth with
and use like you know
it's hard to explain but like you know
sometimes
you gotta yes sir to make it end and and
i'm not i'm not saying
that that's right or that's fair i think
in my case i'm family
if i were a friend or if i were jackie i
get why they kind of battle it out
because they have no reason
to just say all right i'm gonna just let
what you said like blow off my shoulder
they don't feel that way where i'm a
little bit more lenient because of my
children and everyone
and listen teresa and i are we have an
understanding now we
we we know each other she knows like
what she can how far she can go with me
where before i think she used to push me
more she doesn't do that anymore she
knows where i'm gonna like
explode and she's learned me and i've
learned her and i think that we figured
that out
i just don't understand how this gets
resolved and from what your co-stars
have told me it seems like maybe it
doesn't ever get resolved
it just kind of gets put to the side
i don't know is there is there a
resolution for someone's complete
personality
no there's never a resolution for that
how shocked were you by the
did you learn that confidence in jail
comment i was shocked to get that
confidence in jail
in jail yeah that's what i decided i was
like no
it's like two wrongs do not make a right
but i get how if you're coming for me
i'm gonna come back for you so it's like
one of those situations where it's just
like
but jackie comes back with like
everywhere that it's really gonna hurt
you know right we know theresa left the
table i know she comes back
does this fight intersect with then the
cheese plate throwing moment
or are they two separate entities
no i think i was just it was boiling up
and then you'll see us
have a little conversation about joe
judice joe
is backing his sister up saying nothing
negative about her and then he's
mad she's mad at him for that and then
and then i'm
in turn so frustrated because i'm like
when did we ever do anything that you
really
liked like even when we're backing you
up and we're be
and we're like taking your side like you
were the best and you deserve better
we're still
saying it wrong so it's like that's
what's
that is so frustrating because it's like
that situation where you're damned if
you do dance if you don't
this fight has been teased at being at
the level of
the christening
at the level of the retreat apology
is it i mean
i don't know i wouldn't say it the
christening does anything compared to
the i mean let's
no to me absolutely not i mean my son's
christening was like
a fiasco it was like an episode of
godfather or something i don't know what
we were watching at that time but
no i wouldn't say that but i would say
it it will remind you
that they're of that deep hurt that the
family used to feel
it will give you that old vibe of like
wow these people used to really hurt
over these situations and like you bring
it back for two seconds and you can see
it
still runs deep i don't have the trolls
right now just talk because i it really
hurts all like it's really like it runs
deep that situation you know
it is one of those things where we do
watch it for entertainment but at the
end of the day these are
deep seated difficult moments for you as
a family
they really are i know it's all fun and
games to everyone who's watching
but yeah if they give you anxiety these
episodes they do but yet
it's it's not enough to like make you
want to hide under a bed and cry like i
would in season
three when i joined i was like someone
give me somewhere to hide because i'm
never coming out into life again
you know you've grown yeah
um but this moment at the shore with
teresa it does seem to all come to joe
judice is the
crux of the issue there it's hard to
ignore that he is constantly putting
on instagram link in bio link and bio
you know click this
see what my statement on this i'm happy
to help him make money i really
am lincoln bio he's like click i am his
click bait
screw melissa i hate well like it's like
just but yet they'll you'll see it's
like
take his name out of your mouth really
because i don't care
ever to like bring him up believe me
that
so it's like it just gets very one-sided
and joe gets very insulted which
i have to agree with him not because
he's my husband when he's wrong i tell
him he's wrong but like i feel his pain
for me i look at him and i actually like
ah like damn katie like it's very
frustrating
it's very frustrating so what is your
message then to
joe lincoln bio judice is it just stop
oh no we're not i'm not i'm not gonna
come back at him i don't even know i
don't even know
who huh i i don't know who you're
talking about
on the note of you and your joe you've
teased that this season
explores kind of some cracks in your
relationship as you've grown together
what are those issues what are we gonna
see in the coming weeks you're going to
see a lot of it
down the shore we're growing apart maybe
we are maybe we are
i think it was at the worst over the
summer but for the past couple years
we've been struggling a little bit more
arguing more than ever
and i'm being real with it because it's
it is what it is and i feel like we've
come over the hump
of like and and i think almost being on
the show and discussing it in front of
everyone
really made us like whoa this is like
it's real and like we better
check ourselves and like realize that
like our family means more and like
we're losing ourselves here for a minute
and and that's kind of
what happened after we filmed that we
both looked at each other like wow we're
not we're in a bad place and like we got
to like
you know fix this you called me a man
chauvinistic i don't need anyone calling
my husband chauvinistic because whatever
you
think i'm dealing with it's probably
more we've talked over the years
about your evolving thoughts on marriage
and divorce and all that where's your
head at right now how do you feel about
the state of of your marriage today
i feel like we have such a history
together we've been together so long
that i do believe that the grass is not
greener on the other side
it's greener where you water it so i'm
i'm
watering the grass and trying i would
never walk away from joe or this family
without us fighting it and i mean
fighting it tooth and now
and trust me we've been fighting it and
the funny thing is
um like that crazy jennifer who that's a
whole nother thing can't stand with her
but like you know she'll say oh you know
fake this and this is like no it's
actually
really real and and i don't even want
this to be real
and it is you know um but we're never
gonna
it's like we're fighting through it and
i feel like we've come over a hump but
we were in the worst over the summer and
of course the cameras are up so it
caught us
does it jennifer once again make that
dig at you about this specifically are
you talking like
globally that's her commentary on you is
that your name it's commentary jennifer
because she's like never
she never has anything so she just goes
for like let me like talk about melissa
so maybe people
see my name talking about melissa like
she needs to get a grip she's such a
wannabe i can't with her
i was gonna ask where things stand now
it seems like
not much better but like come on like i
can't like
first of all like i'll never forget she
goes from like the first season like oh
my god i don't drink i don't drink it
you're like like you're laying on the
floor
bombed like uh like you're in a sorority
like come on
it's ridiculous you want to talk about
like ridiculous like she just
she will do anything for attention and
that doesn't work i like authentic
people with her it's like oh like what
should i do
like oh i'm gonna get like no i have no
time for jennifer i really don't sorry i
just
don't i feel like she talks about her
whole family
she talks about everyone other than
herself and her marriage it's like i'm
gonna use my like
first we're gonna go with my brother
then my parents marriage now we're gonna
go to my daughter but like no we want to
hear about you
is there anything do you got anything no
she doesn't she just wants to say
well this is self-absorbed all day
melissa's cell phones that's all you got
like at least give me something better
than that
it's like geez it's like you know she
sees
jackie's having a real argument with
teresa she's like all right i guess i
i'm gonna i need to go for melissa like
no why don't you really get mad at
something for real instead of just like
pull things out of your ass that's what
i want to say to jennifer
okay i mean she did get involved in a
little drama
with you and her thought on the whole
michelle thing is that michelle gave her
that information to go tell you to be a
friend
do you think that was michelle's
intention or do you think michelle was
trying to stoke a little
something um i think that michelle was
realizing you know oh i have to come and
bring it and so maybe i'll use this
which by the way it was completely false
it was another case of people who are
just hungry
and thirsty and i don't know if joe and
i have targets on our heads like if
you're hungry and you're on
this show here we are like i don't know
if we're wearing some type of target but
it seems to be
how you know i think throughout the
years everyone's very used to that so
uh no surprises here and um
jennifer what the funny thing is with
jennifer
i actually gave her the benefit of the
debt i was like no listen i'm not gonna
like kill the messenger i get it you're
telling me i appreciate it
but she doesn't have any guts it's like
she in her all of her confessionals
it was like probably true it's probably
this it's like
she talks when you're not in front of
her and now i'm seeing all that i'm like
all right so maybe i should have killed
the messenger or gave her a hard time
instead you know melissa over here gives
her the benefit of the doubt i'm like
it's all right someone told you
something you're telling me
but no not to my face like in the
confessionals
she's got a lot she's got a lot to say
you know it's like say to my face
people do seem a little confused about
what growing with gorga
is what people were getting out of that
experience can you explain what the
program is and why people would pay to
go to it
sure so i mean there was hundreds of
people that actually paid to come
because joe um joe came from two parents
that were immigrants that had nothing
his father was a shoemaker
his mother uh drove a bus they were
hard-working
people okay and he has made it he is
self-made
he's made it to where he is by starting
in a landscaping company
investment properties how to get the
loans
how to have people invest in you believe
in you and worked up to what we have
today
so he does have a lot to offer a lot to
teach that's what growa gorga is and but
we had one and then the pandemic
happened so there was never
another one but they wanted to go and do
more and that was the thing
if they did more they were joe was like
all right this was a lot of work
going forward we can split it that was
the deal
moving forward we've never moved forward
we're in a pandemic
you know we're not having large groups
of people come together so right
right we were like what's happening and
what are you talking about
you know that makes sense to me
um can you explain the philosophy behind
joe's instagram account
who's making those posts and where does
he find these quotes
okay i'm gonna be so real with you on
this like and you have to believe this
you have to believe this
he does it himself he's
we like we laugh at him all day i have
to let joe be joe
and he loves these quotes he loves to
like say quotes and find clothes and
like
it's so like not like he doesn't even
care he doesn't even think about it but
it's like
i'm always like what's this mean what's
this
so it's even a little bit of a mystery
to you too
tonia will come down the stairs and be
like dad
what is this and he's like what it's
funny everybody loves it we're like
you just showed two grasshoppers humping
each other like why
and he's like i don't know go get me ice
cream like he
that's joe like i don't know how else to
explain it like and that's real that is
real
he doesn't even think about it he
doesn't care he just doesn't
you know on the note of antonia i feel
like joe's gotten a little bit of
pushback
over some comments he's made kind of
these old-fashioned views on how to
parent
a a girl coming into young womanhood
look at your daughter
what is that are you willing to put her
on birth control
has he changed his approach at all i
think being on this show actually helped
him a lot
it does because he does see his tweets
he sees when people are like you're
wrong like you're
wrong with your daughter you're wrong
with your wife you're wrong and he it
has helped i'm telling you the show has
helped us
in that manner because it softens him
and he reads them and he's like
all right and i'm like they can't all be
wrong joe we can't all be crazy
he's like all right you know so it does
help i was thinking just in talking to
you now of like
would this melissa be sitting in front
of me had the show never entered your
life i feel like
you probably wouldn't be this evolved of
a person
if you hadn't had this experience that
means you're right and that makes me
very sad
i don't know if i would have i don't
know if i would have had the opportunity
i know that that's who i am deep inside
that's how i lived before my job i was
working three jobs when he met me
literally i had three jobs i was putting
myself through college so i was very
independent you know i was like
living on my own and i think that that's
who i am but then
i also had beliefs in marriage and
wanting to
you know play house and and all that but
it's really deep down inside i am
a workaholic independent
like get out of my way type of girl to
answer your question
i don't know which would make me very
sad because i'll be honest another
dad on listing i wouldn't turn back for
anything
like right i'm happy with the way it
turned out and i
i can't say the same for joe i can't say
that he's happy
but i am and that's the problem listen i
can't tell you what would have happened
naturally if i wasn't on
if i didn't have all these opportunities
and i wasn't opening businesses
and running around the world doing what
i'm doing i don't know that i wouldn't
have just found it inside myself and
said hey listen this is not i gotta go
to work like i don't know
i don't know but i do think that the
show has definitely
helped me to to get back to who i really
was
well i think that also contributes then
uh
to kind of the the allegation that you
do do stuff just
for show or for the show because it's
like well no we're watching a woman
come back into her own and explore
different parts of herself
each year right like it's so real it's
frustrating for me
if people say that that's not that i
wouldn't so bravo is not down with that
you start doing any of that you're gone
you know
you're right they are not down with that
listen i've been on reality tv
since i was only married for for four
years
before i have been on tv i don't think
everyone understands like my
almost my whole married life i am on
reality tv i'm definitely at a
at a point where i'm busier than i've
ever been so
you know men get insecure he's having
like a moment you know you gotta give it
to him i guess
has there ever been the conversation of
joe wanting you off the show saying
let's go back to
living up as private of a life as you
can after you've had
such a big life on on tv yes um
yeah he always says like well what are
you gonna do when it's over
i'm like all the other things that i do
like i'm not
it's not the end all for me at all um
and he's he's gotten a question from
interviews before where they've said
if you can do it again would you do it
or would you not he always says no i
would not take it
and i always say i would right that's
his life has also grown and his business
has also grown because of it so i feel
like that's
i don't fully believe him when he says
that something like grow with gorga or
writing his book those opportunities
come because of the show exactly
that kind of stuff is great for him yes
there are these fan conversations
happening like a cat
shake up you know maybe that would come
after the season do you think that would
happen after
i don't think it's happening i think
you've a solid group i think they would
add someone
i don't think anyone's going anywhere if
that's my personal preference
i think they would add someone and i
hope they do
i gotta wrap up here but i do have to
ask you what do you make
of gia's sad song becoming the anthem of
2021
and cardi b endorsing it i can't i can't
believe how many times cardi b has like
said something about it it's crazy it's
must it's so crazy because i see us
standing there over here while she's
singing this
and it's actually such a sad waking up
in the morning
thinking about so many things i just
wish things would get
better i'm trying to get rid of them but
nothing seems to stay the same
it was such a sad day and for now
everyone to kind of make it like a funny
thing
um it's great it's like kind of like it
went full circle i guess it's like
see you can and now g is happy and she's
doing great so
i think it's inspiring to show like this
little girl was like going through
something and now
we're all like singing about it on tick
tock it's crazy i think it's it's insane
i'm like
it's i'm sure she's like it's like on
cloud nine over it it's so funny well
yeah and she's it's really has gone full
circle
because she even made a tick tock waking
up in the morning
thinking about so many things now it's
gotta be ten years later that was season
three so it's like
ten years right so yeah she uh her first
reaction i
when it went viral she was like i'll
never live this down but i think once
cardi b
endorsed it it was like okay now i'm
gonna go take it
yay